then again some rehearse hearing him
sing with this band his band is
tremendous by the way your guitar player
matters under it's out of this world his
ranges of vocalist is just incredible
notice there's nothing he couldn't say
this has been amazing I think we enjoy a
couple pastimes together I think we
enjoy some stuff together but you know
he's just a very very very humble guy
I've met a lot of people that I have
never I wish I didn't meet you know I'm
saying I get you I don't I don't I'm
glad this happened we are all very glad
that it happened - so I know you guys
have to get in there thank you so much
for stopping might have the best time
tonight okay
over to you thanks dude honestly if I
was any better I probably have to
complain it's too good well this weekend
another CC may speak to me that their
friends and family yeah a good time well
listen tell us about five nominations
you were tied for the most with James
Barker band like how pumped are you were
you even expecting that no not at all
you never expect these things cos
this is a pretty crazy business that
we're all part of but I feel very
blessed to share that with James and you
know obviously given his entire crew
these are incredible entertainers I'm to
rub shoulders with look at everybody
you've seen so far and you will on this
red carpet yeah all of us were
collectively at the top of our game we
loved this weekend
we left our support one another so it's
a great time - well speaking of
celebrating you got three kids at home
so are you and your wife is a day-night
tonight no I got my kiss there
Neela's three arias to leo seven months
old it's a good time for all of us
awesome I bet well listen
congratulations and everything and by
the way the news signal
tell us about drink about me with the
features of the Bachelorette right Chris
tonight yeah so we've got from bachelor
nation nation obviously Jason tardik and
it's much much better happen I'll say
that Kaylin Bristow so incredible people
were so thankful that they were able to
be a part of our video and I think bring
your vision to life and the biggest
thing for us is that we absolutely love
this song you know me and my team my
family but it's a video that truly
brings it to life to take these lyrics
and this story put it on the big screen
and they did an incredible job
yeah well listen it's an incredible year
for you five-time nominee good luck
tonight enjoy the evening thanks for
stopping by my pleasure thanks for
debuting the video the other day means a
lot to us no worries all right Brett
Kissel and let's throw it over to Cheryl
now
thanks so much Jeff okay Brett Kissel
has five nomination tonight and so do
these gentlemen right here the James
Barker band okay who shed the most tears
when you heard about the nomination
Connor Connor is a big cry guy I mean on
top of just having all those nominations
what was it that sort of got you the
[Music]
[Applause]
moments choice for sure
your careers really skyrocketed over the
last little while what was the first
thing you bought for yourself oh okay
oh my goodness probably I bought a brand
new like custom guitar very sensible yes
exactly this maybe it's too sensible I
didn't buy anything cool yet
would you get anyone else buy anything
cool I paid my father back and still
trying to pay him back so that's what is
it good son right there I have to say I
mean you and I bought brand-new trucks
like you really went shopping a bit like
going and like checking the cache itself
I like amazing congratulations on all
your success and so much more to come
thanks for stopping by all right now
we're gonna throw things over to Jeff
who's with one of country music's
hottest couples now joined by Megan
Patrick and her boyfriend Mitchell
Tenpenny great to see you guys and
welcome to see CMAs
I know there's a lot of big things
happening in your life including you
guys just bought a new home in Nashville
[Applause]
pretty much for me to have when I bought
a house so yeah Mitchell you're shaking
your head though well then let me ask
you this question I want you to finish
the line for me if you can okay first
comes love then comes house absolutely
tell me how excited you are tonight you
of course are the reigning female artist
of the year
Megan Patrick how would you describe
your life right now
not a lot of sleep really busy but I
mean I like being busy I mean being busy
means you're doing something right so
just being on the road a bunch I just
put my new EP out on Friday which I'm
getting a lot of great response from so
my life is pretty damn good
did you just Instagram that your life is
full of dry shampoo and grilled cheese
cheese in this business all right well
great to see you both enjoy the evening
thank you so much all right all right
thanks Jeff well their last album was
called happy endings but we're just
getting started here with these guys all
the way from Nashville it's Old Dominion
who will be performing tonight at this
year's see CMAs upcoming third album the
self-titled and features the band on the
cover of the may of the album for the
first time is this a rebirth the
reintroduction like you're on the cover
this time well you got throw a curveball
and weirdly the curveball is us on the
cover so people expect us to be
something different and that is
different for us this is it like a
rebirth for the group or I don't think
it's necessarily a rebirth it still
sounds like us but it is next step I
would say so yeah how does it feel to be
here tonight amongst all the artists and
all the fans it's exciting that it's
always fun to do this and just you can
get a chance to see why we got into it
in the first place and now the fans are
out there
that's what we love to do amazing you
guys are on the road a lot and you know
very very busy who this kind of takes
the dad role with you guys like make
sure everybody's on time we are where
he's not even on camera but he's amazing
alright and he makes sure he wherever he
goes we just fall in line well make sure
he makes you guys that are up on stage
and everything goes well tonight thank
you so much for your time have a great
time back to YouTube and we've got much
more ahead from Calgary just moskaluke
and the wreck laws will join us at the
red carpet
don't go anywhere you're watching ET
Canada at the CMA Awards we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and joined now by three-time nominee
tonight jess moskaluke and her husband
clay who's walking the carpet for the
first time looks so good and you know
what you and I have something in common
because this is my first time hosting a
red carpet I think we can both say thank
goodness for Jess to tell us Jess about
the new addition to your family you guys
just got a new puppy we did we just
rescued our second while our second
puppy together so her name is blue and
she is a little quirky so yeah there she
oh we're just getting her from service a
rescue yeah it's a rescue a local one to
us and Yorkton Saskatchewan called paws
and claws
clay actually named her after her one
blue eye alright so how does the house
training going oh it's going great you
know like this just show it up on Sunday
with a puppy and then left on Wednesday
and I was thrown to the wolves all right
not only a new puppy but you've got new
music coming when yes October I'm so so
excited I can't wait to show you all
right well listen good luck tonight
we'll be rooting for you and thanks for
stopping by
thanks so much chef good to see you
alright let's go over to Cheryl now
Steph these two are seriously one of my
favorites it's Jen and Stewart better
known as the wreck laws congratulations
on your win last night for top-selling
Canadian single of the year and for long
live the night which I was blaring in my
hotel room getting ready today which is
just you're amazing and you're not done
you're also nominated for three more
awards tonight I know you guys have said
before that you get a little bit nervous
in front of big crowds from time to time
so what's happening inside you right now
how are you feeling we're just taking it
one step at a time like this we're doing
the red carpet this is amazing but I
mean it is a big moment for sure there's
a lot of people watching and there's
really only you can do it one time so
regardless we have to go out there and
we have to do it and we're just excited
for the opportunity amazing I'll be
singing along the whole time okay and
how are you feeling tonight I mean you
must your family must be just so excited
for all of them my parents are in town
they've never been to Calgary they're
gonna go explore the mountains this week
and they are like also last night
getting the award from you it's very
special you guys have a new video
dropping soon right and I hear it's
pretty epic what can you tell us about
it oh my gosh it honestly took a couple
days to film because there was so many
things you wanted to do with it but we
got a bunch of our friends together and
just had the most epic days involving
water canoeing golfing at people in a
canoe thing I can't wait to see the
video so much love to you guys and I
can't wait to see you out there tonight
thank you so much okay back to you Jeff
and I'm joined now by a guy in a song I
can't get out of my head because I love
whisky or I love country music or
probably both Morgan joins us now Morgan
how are you I'm doing good how you doing
really good welcome to see CMAs do I
have yeah listen we got to talk a bit
about the hair if we could okay I
understand you were the man responsible
for bringing the mullet back I feel like
I played a small part in it yeah man
it's a I didn't really expect it to
become a thing like it has but it's this
coldest to be in that movement yeah yeah
you having a little fun with it yeah of
course I am yeah all the shows that we
play back in the States
yeah well here too we played at boosting
boots and hearts a couple weeks ago and
it seems like there's just every show
there's more and more bullets in the
crowd so yeah proud of it well the guy
with maybe the original country mullet
is co-hosting the show tonight Billy Ray
Cyrus bit of an inspiration you know not
necessarily for Emilio's
and I was looking at photo albums of my
parents and whenever my parents got
married my dad had a mullet and like I
wanted to get one - yeah well listen
we're excited to have you here before I
let you go is there any country music
action country music Canadian country
music is having such a moment right now
is there anybody that is really going to
rock it up for you yeah I know this girl
named Mackenzie Porter yeah me and her
on the same label and I've been
listening to her music we have the same
producer so I'm rooting for her yeah
okay and speaking of that gonna ask you
about this current hit you've got with
Diplo how'd that come about yeah it's
it's obviously a little bit different
than what I normally do but it's a they
originally sent over a couple a couple
like this to my manager and I wasn't
even included not just he's like man I
know these ideas are great but I'm gonna
send you something back that you guys
can you know take it however you want
and they ended up scratching the other
ideas and went up with us so it's a it's
a song that I'm proud of and I'm glad to
be able to hopefully maybe bring country
music system people who have heard it
yeah listen
sounds great it's great to have you here
thanks for dropping by thank you for
having us all right over to Cheryl
all right we're not done here in Calgary
not by a long shot coming up we'll have
Lindsay al Paul Brandt and so many more
this is eg Canada at the CMAs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to et Canada at the CMAs
it's my co-host from last night's gala
dinner Lindsey Lu took home interactive
artists of the year and you have three
nominations tonight including female
artist of the year you are quickly
becoming a really powerful force in
country music right now not only here
but south of the border you've got your
CMA nomination give me a word that would
describe your life right now grateful
I'm really grateful I've worked so hard
at this ever since I was a little girl
and now to be stepping into some of my
dreams that I've watched ever since I
was like yay high and being able to
share stages with artists that I look up
to and were my idols and now I look at
them as my peers I mean it feels surreal
a lot of times but I'm just truly
grateful
well you're incredible and you're
performing tonight with high Valley
which we were very excited about tell us
something that we may not know about the
boys what slick some dirt you can give
us what don't we know that you can share
they're so fun they're so funny have
such a good sense of humor and actually
they they grew up like they were such a
close family
that they the first time I met them they
didn't really know how to play a cover
song they knew how to play like I'll fly
away and like church hymns but I was
like so like stairway to heaven and
they're like what's that and I'm like
really
I can play stairway to heaven for the
first time for you and they're like
what's that song and so but they're so
sweet I love them like brothers and
we're gonna have a lot of oh yeah you
look absolutely stunning but please tell
everybody about your spray Hemet your
your spray tan mishap that we saw on
your Instagram I posted about it what
happened okay so the moment right dad's
got a spray tan guys and as I'm walking
out of the spray tan booth I
accidentally hit the door and I was like
oh and I scraped off my spray tan so as
you can see it has like a diagonal curve
on my back which I have a long ponytail
right now so you can't even see it but
I'm not even see Javas right that's
right like nothing looked amazing see
there it is ponytail can't even see it
you look gorgeous have the best time
tonight and congratulations on
everything over to you Jeff join now by
its Neil towns to nail it is great to
see you welcome to the CMAs oh thank you
it's so good to see you what a great
night well listen it's already been a
great weekend for you because you've won
a couple of Si CMAs right
crazy yes so grateful to be a part of
this community and
great celebration and so glad to be back
home here in Alberta I bet I know we're
so excited to have them back here for
the first time in 14 years well tell us
about the song somebody's daughter and
what that means to you in particular
so important to me since fired by a
driver I took with my mom we saw this
young girl standing on the side
[Music]
kind of wondered what her story was
everybody's got a story so it's it's
just it means so much to me if people
heard this song out there and been
turning it up and singing along really
so grateful well I know one of those
people that's been turning it up and
singing along is none other than
Dierks Bentley here
with what did you learn from your time
with Turks Turks is an incredible
so kinda journeys heats up the best care
of us on the road he made us feel so
welcome as an opening act I feel like I
learned something every single night I
sat and watched his show
and also just alert our retreats people
on an off the stage got such a good
culture
people we had so much fun well listen
we're gonna have fun tonight already a
double winner good luck in there you
look fantastic thanks for stopping by
thank you so much let's run over to
Cheryl now thanks so much Jeff I'm so
honored to have Paul brand with me for
nominations tonight but on top of that
you're also this year's winner of the
2019 slate music Humanitarian Award for
not in my city tell us a little bit
about why it's and so important for you
to shine the light on this car yeah you
know it's a challenging topic you know
the issue of human trafficking it is now
one of the fastest growing crimes in
Canada today and that feeling of
discomfort that it gives people it's
exactly what traffickers are hoping that
we'll have to discuss this issue the way
that we can actually save victims and
help survivors through this horrible
crime last night when you were getting
your award
it's very emotional it is an incredibly
brave woman and is doing an incredible
job of now helping other formers
performer traffic victims to get
lives and to just be able to thrive
which is what we love to see Jeff and I
are wearing your can we see the shoe I
don't know if you guys can see but he
has these shoes there we go you're good
balance I'll hold you
of course now listen we're here
supporting with this pin but how can
people at home get involved and sort of
also lend their support well you know
not in my city dot CA is where you go
and all of these designs that you see
were inspired my party great friend of
mine who helps me with all of my fashion
needs and you can actually get some of
those designs on out of my city dossier
and become an ally such a legend so
incredible and the work that you're
doing here is so important so thank you
so much back to you Jeff
you can literally feel the excitement we
were just moments away from the big show
but stay with us we have one special
surprise left to share with you and
that's next
you're watching ET Canada at the CMA
Awards
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to et Canada at the sea
CMAs we're moments away from the big
show but we have one very important
piece of business to take care of
let's welcome Chad Brownlee here to
Calgary are you doing I'm doing
fantastic how're you I'm doing really
great listen I hope you have some extra
room in your luggage because we want to
present you with this double gold plaque
for your two singles dear drunk knee and
forevers got to start somewhere here you
go you are the only Canadian artist to
have back-to-back gold singles in 2019
how does it feel unbelievable actually
this is the very first time I've seen
this thank you so much I'm shocked
it's a beautiful surprise the night has
just started so you know what have a
fantastic night to make congratulations
it was good to see you again
ok so I've had an absolute blast here on
the CC and a red carpet now I'm heading
backstage to interview all the winners
what a show over to you Jeff
alright time for us to step aside as the
big show is about to start thank you so
much for joining us for the red carpet
you can watch the show on Global's
YouTube channel and don't forget all the
highlights tomorrow on ET Canada have a
great night and thanks for watching
ET Canada at the sea CMA Awards
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]